Can you go over the sides on a blood test that may indicate metastasis to bone?
So so on a standard blood test you have a standard blood test would be
That you go in do an annual blood test. You're doing a CBC with a different shell. I mean that's your white blood cell
Right red blood cell and a different shell of white blood cells do neutrophils lipocytes blah blah blah. And then
There's nothing really on there that show any signs of metastasis is a mode. It's the complete metabolic panel, which is a standard blood test
a complete metabolic pedal
Is going to show your liver markers and your chloride and your calcium and your you know CO2
So what is a side remember blood tests are just signs. They're like them
They're like little indicators. They don't tell you exactly what's going on, but they give you clues and you compare it to other things
So
with what would be clues to metastasis to bone if you already have a diagnosis of cancer
You would look for an elevated alcohol and phosphatase
with usually spared AST and ALT
So typically AST, ALT and alcohol and phosphates are considered liver markers
except AL alcohol and phosphatase is also produced by bone. It's produced by
Your liver. It's produced by your intestinal tract. It's produced by if you pregnant your placenta
so
But if your alcohol and phosphatase is elevated and your AST is within normal limits and your ALT isn't with the normal limits and your calcium is elevated
That's a big clue that there may be metastasis to bone and I've talked to people on the phone that say
Well, no, I had a PET scan, you know two months ago when it was normal
Well, again, there has to be you know fairly large, you know, it has to be three million cells large before
It's going to be seen on a PET scan. You can pick clues up
By that. So if I had a normal PET scan three months ago, but now my alcohol and phosphatase is elevated and my calcium is elevated
I'd be I'd have some concerns and I may want to
investigate
so remember they're just clues
to
signal and investigation
so
There's other reasons so if a person doesn't have a no-dagnosis of cancer, so let's say they're just going in for a regular
Workup, they don't have cancer and they had elevated calcium levels. The first thing you think of is
Parathyroid tumor not a thyroid tumor, but a parathyroid gland tumor
very it's actually quite common
and the treatment for it is to remove the parathyroid glands
Because the parathyroid tumor is going to cause an elevated calcium
Now what else would cause an elevated calcium? Well with
Bode destruction will cause an elevated calcium
So if I have cancer
Diagnosis and sometimes people don't know they have a cancer and they find out when they already have
Metz to the bone. I didn't find out eye and cancer until I had metz to the to the intestinal tract the colorectal area
But so it's not uncommon that you don't know you have cancer and tell your stage 4 you already have a testicist and
It isn't all a totally uncommon that you don't know you have cancer until you find out you have a testic
So that would be a clue if you don't have cancer or you don't know you have cancer or certainly if you know you have cancer
If you have an elevated alcohol and phosphatase with a spared AST and a spared ALT in an elevated calcium level
because
Cancer that metastasizes to bone will be lidic so it'll be it'll cause destruction of bone